alright John Lee we just got back from
seeing Dishonored 2 we had a chance to
play about an hour of a particular new
mission I got two plays Corvo you got to
play as Emily so let's just start can
you tell us a little bit about what we
saw today yeah so we got to play a is
the fourth mission so it's part way
through the game it is the clockwork
mansion which is sort of like this crazy
mansion built by this eccentric
basically like master inventor guy who
really likes to hear himself talk it
really likes to toy with people uh he
was in our ear the entire mission just
like talking [ __ ] the whole time not if
you kill him early he doesn't that's
Trevor the interesting thing as with
every dishonored game you can really
kind of find your own path and some
paths are quicker than others like i
actually discovered really early on that
you can actually slip into like in
between the walls of the house as like
the floors shift and like staircases
appear and disappear you can actually
like find your way behind the gears and
like leave the house proper and start
moving through the walls and find all
kinds of grass oh that's like the cool
thing about this mansion is that it's
constantly moving around it's like a
Disney World esta like theme park where
all these crazy like robot contraptions
are everywhere and go starts moving and
then yeah you can get through the walls
and you can kind of see like behind
everything yeah and it's all analog
which school that you can see the gears
turning you can see where like a
particular plate might have like swung
down and then got pushed into position
there was so much thought put into the
way that it was assembled it's almost
like this could actually be absurd way
the level itself was was basically the
puzzle of the mission the world itself
was kind of a puzzle which was really
interesting yeah I mean I've always
thought that was like dishonored
strength is is it throws you into this
very grand like large area and then
hasn't tackle it in multiple ways so I
know for me the way I got to you have
two objectives you have to save this guy
who's a character from the first acesso
glove the the scientist gamer and then
you also have to take care of
as a Djinn Djinn take care of ya hear
engine dodge grand adventure that we
mentioned the multiple ways to take care
of him as with the first one you go
through a lethal or non-lethal route at
one point I was trying to figure out how
to get to him and I saw I was looking at
a balcony and you couldn't quite reach
it from the balcony but I saw there was
like this little vent and star like I
kind of hop off of it onto the vent very
precariously and then I was able to leap
over there gosh you're like sort of that
off the wall thinking where the game
encourages you to look around and be
like you know just try this man like
sure like and if it doesn't work like
hey hopefully you saved right before
burial appropriate I went and did that
and then my alternate route was I am
there I had this ability called um I was
like shadow shadow step i believe and
basically you turn into this like
shadowy creature that like crawls on the
floor and it's actually a little broken
i thought because you can kind of just
get past anybody with it and like you're
just like crawling around the floor and
they I guess they just don't see you
right and then you but you also have the
option to just take care of them both
lethally or non-lethally and I took the
lethal option and you just grab him and
you just your rip in manhasset did
mention at the beginning of our demo
that that we've been given more powers
than we would typically have at that
point in the game because I mentioned it
was only the fourth chapter is probably
not super far into the game so it's
possible if that's a later power that
you unlock or earn and I'm guessing it
probably used up quite a bit of you are
sort of like magic power the blue bar on
the hood I definitely you can't just
spam it or anything like that but yeah
they gave you like I mean I had like
regular dark sleeping darts I had like a
gun I had a gun that shot explosives
which was really awesome cuz it's just
like their clockwork soldiers which take
a fair amount to hit I'm actually really
cool because they have them different
points on their body they're white and I
guess it's like they were they're
attached to each other and you can
actually aim and shoot them off
individually so you can like shoot off
their arm or shoot off their leg and the
explosive lunches it just blows them up
you
oh it is pretty cool to watch them fall
to pieces I definitely chucked a grenade
it more than one yep more than one clock
for children to watch them is completely
fall apart but they are really
interesting enemies to fight they take
damage much better than just average
human enemies like you can't just come
straight at one you really have to
position yourself appropriately and kind
of cut come at them from the right way
or use the right tool to take him down
you can't simply like charge at them and
try to slice them up it just isn't gonna
work yeah you'll die really quickly in
fact I actually had a issue where I died
21 and I was like okay whatever and then
the autosave loaded me like right before
it leaps on me so I just got stuck in
this loop it likes killing me three or
four times thankfully my hard save was
like a room right before so I wasn't
that big of a deal but that did happen
to me that was kind of a bummer is so
playing as Corvo it was interesting
because I remember all those powers in
the first game but in this particular
setting I feel like I was able to use
them in kind of different ways and
actually ended up in a very different
part of the world than you I was doing
all like the weird behind the wall stuff
so I made it down to sokoloff I like had
to solve what was essentially a tile
puzzle to get like the walls to shift in
the right way to get him out so again it
was really interesting to see how the
level itself was kind of the driving
mechanic of this particular mission it
was really cool and what's crazy is
according according to Bethesda each
mission is going to kind of have its own
version of this like we've seen the
sandstorms and another mission in
earlier demos there was a demo at e3
where you were able to like manipulate
time and step through history basic
right so it's gonna be really
interesting to see what the other levels
hold because i really enjoy the jinn
dosh mansion like the way everything
kind of fit together in this really
intricate way so excited for more of
that
what's always been interesting to me
about dishonor it is it's the kind of
game you can be bad at but want to get
better at like eventually as you get a
feel for the powers and as you begin to
expand and experiment if the game really
just kind of blossoms and provides all
these different opportunities for youth
player which is really cool so yeah it
can be very frustrating at times and I
think a lot of people will be frustrated
by it but it but in my experience
especially today the more that you work
at it the more you can kind of get out
of the game that's my favorite kind of
game is where it rewards the player who
takes the opportunity to like really
like learn and get better at the game's
mechanics alright so that was our demo
of dishonor to from earlier today
hopefully we're gonna see a little bit
more of the game before it's out it's
due out on November 11 so we have a
little bit of time so stay put on
gamespot com for more coverage of
dishonor to and basically everything
video games I can either come I'll see
Josh